le variant omikron représente une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour ceux qui
l'attaquent gravement mais
paradoxalement il est peut être une
bonne nouvelle pour le reste du monde en
effet les experts de la santé estime que
la diffusion massive de ce variant moins
dangereux que delta peut faire basculer
la situation tout d'abord omicron est
inarrêtable la certitude c'est que le
vario micron est amené à circuler et à
traverser la planète il est tellement
contagieux qu'il circule alors faisons
avec il y a plusieurs mois emmanuel
macron n'avait-il pas prédit qu'il
faudrait vivre avec le virus ce scénario
se précise selon l'agencé européenne du
médicament
la contagiosité de ce virus pourrait
permettre d'atteindre la fameuse
immunité collective pour la population
cette protection est rendu possible
grâce à la combinaison de deux facteurs
la défense immunitaire conférait grâce
aux vaccins et celles découlant de
l'infection marco cavalleri chef de la
stratégie vaccinale de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments a expliqué
que nous sommes toujours dans une
situation préoccupante en pleine
pandémie mais il a dessiné le scénario
du futur
quand cette vague aura traversé l'europe
et le reste du monde beaucoup de monde
aura été exposés au virus et or a
développé une forte immunité ouvrira la
voie à l'endémicité
le colis 19 pourrait devenir à terme un
virus saisonnier comme un autre à
combattre avec des mesures barrières des
rappels espaces et les traitements qui
ne manqueront pas d'être mise au point
dans les années à venir l'autre bonne
nouvelle c'est que le renouvellement à
l'infini des deux n'est pas conseillée
dans la mesure où tout le monde devrait
à brève échéance développer un haut
niveau d'immunité l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a estimé que
l'injection de doses répétées n'était
pas une stratégie durable d'autant que
les premiers vaccins servait
majoritairement à éviter les formes
graves il faut aller plus loin l' oms
demande que les futurs vaccins contre le
coc vide 19 avec un impact élevé en
matière de transmission et de prévention
de l'infection en plus de prévenir les
formes graves de la maladie et la mort
soit développée et quelques pays
entrevoyant lueur dans la nuit ont
commencé à assouplir leurs règles comme
l'espagne qui bien qu'en pic épidémique
veut considérer que la prochaine étape
sera de traiter le coc vite d'une
manière plus proche de ce que l'on fait
avec la grippe pedro sanchez le premier
ministre espagnol a considéré que son
pays était sur le bon chemin pour je
cite ne plus considérer le coronavirus
comme une pandémie mais comme une
maladie endémique une maladie
respiratoire de plus israël a également
revu sa stratégie est couvert ses
frontières les grands rassemblements ils
sont de nouveau autorisées même esprit
aux états unis bien qu accablé par un
nombre d'hospitalisations record
l'amérique se veut optimiste
le conseiller de la maison blanche pour
la crise sanitaire anthony falchi
estiment qu'ils n'en sont pas au stade
où ils peuvent dire de façon acceptable
vivant avec le virus mais je pense que
nous y arriverons at il affirmé l'ong
janvier mais cet enthousiasme ne doit
pas nous amener à relâcher notre
vigilance ce sont des pays à forte
pression hospitalière qui rêvent d'un
monde aux colis d'endémie qu'ils
maîtrisaient les nombreuses restrictions
actuelles permet d'éviter le pire il ya
encore beaucoup à faire avant que la
situation ne se stabilise avant de
remiser les tests les masques et les
vaccins en novembre des experts du
groupe scientifique indépendant sages
qui conseillent le gouvernement
britannique ont estimé cette période à 5
ans
car au micro n'a pas encore contaminé le
monde entier mais d'autres variantes
sont à redouter